[Musique]
Saint-Pétersbourg la ville de tous les
extrêmes capitale impériale fondée il y
a 300 ans sur les rives de la mer
Baltique par Pierre Legrand elle est
déchue sous l'air
soviétique depuis peu elle renoue avec
son glorieux
[Musique]
passé aujourd'hui comme hier la ville
offre de visages aux hivers polaires et
leur nuits interminables succèdent
presque sans transition des étés parfois
caniculaire au jour sans fin un climat
limité à de saisons très contrasté
auquel les habitants ont su
s'adapter depuis la chute du communisme
de nombreux pétersbourgeois amoureux de
leur ville participent avec passion à
son nouveau
rayonnement nous avons passé un an
auprès de Vladimir na qui se rêve en
pierre et fait construire la réplique du
premier navire de la flotte russe
leava il nous faut à tous une goutte de
romantisme un sens de l'aventure avoir
envie de faire renître le
[Musique]
passé et sa brigade de softe plongeur
protèg toute l'année les ptersbourgeois
des dangers de la Neva et de la mer
[Musique]
Baltique
notre boulot est difficile on travaille
sous pression on est confronté à des
chocs psychologiques à des
risquesmonellement
durronter nimporteelle
situation dinur français inst depuis
ansron l'IV pour relever
défensé SC les plus beau joyau du musée
de l'Ermitage
[Musique]
sur
parfaite entre passé et avenir entre été
et hiver c'est la double vie de
[Musique]
Saint-Pétersbourg le plus souvent le
cœur historique de Saint-Pétersbourg se
découvre par ses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
canaux mais depuis quelques temps
certains l'explorent un peu
différemment pour cel bra les interdits
et prendre de la
hauteur
bonjour je
suis je suis votre guide l'imme ne fait
pas de bruit dans la cour ni dans
l'escalier il pas que les
habit
[Musique]
au programme aujourd'hui une balade a en
avoir le
vertige Nastia et ses amis font du
roofing des visites clandestines sur les
toits de la
ville c'est
magnifique une vue imprenable sur la
cathédrale Saint-
Isaac la forteresse Pierre et
Paul la cathédrale Saint Sauveur sur le
sangversé le palais du prince Michel
ou encore l'incontournable musée de
[Musique]
l'Ermitage vu sous cet angle c'est
vraiment la première fois que je vois la
ville que je n'avais encore jamais vu la
Neva comme ça j'ai envie de m'y
baigner riche de son architecture et de
son histoire impériale Saint-Pétersbourg
est devenu en quelques années la
capitale du roofing en
[Musique]
Russie mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait pour pa
le guide la seule vue ne suffit plus
alors la tête dans la NA et les pieds
dans les nuages le panorama Pr
moi je suis sous le
choc c'est uneue imprable c'est génial
de voir la ville comme
çaver noir et blan
[Musique]
grise elle repris toutes
couleurs le pied sur la NA une répque
d'un navire de guerre du 18 siècle et la
forteresse Pierre et Paul rappelle ce
que doit encore aujourd'hui la ville à
Pierre son fondateur
on va s'asseoir où sur
ça ici je perçois la ville comme un tout
son esprit son atmosphère je comprends
qu'on est entouré
d'eau c'est ce qui rend cette
vque quand Pier le grand a décidé de
construire cette ville ici on lui a dit
mais qu'est-ce que tu fais tu veux
construire une ville sur des maréages et
lui a répondu mais c'est très bien je
veux qu'on soit entouré par
[Musique]
l'eau pendant ce temps sur le fleuve
Neva Vladimir constructeur naval de
renaom se rent à son bureau en
[Musique]
bateau
c'est la forteresse
pierp pour la Russie c'est un lieu très
important de nombreux événements
historiques sont produit mais surt c'est
icié
SaintPétersbourg la forteresse a
toujours été importante dans ma vie
parce que j'ai grandi juste de l'autre
côté dans le quartier de la petogradka
notre maison était voisine de la
forteresse au sommet il y a un ange
c'est l'ange protecteur de
Saint-Pétersbourg il y a une dizaine
d'années l'ange a été retiré pour être
restauré et tous les habitants ont eu
peur de se retrouver sans sa protection
il a fallu le remplacer au plus
vite attaché aux traditions Vladimir dès
qu'il en a l'occasion se déplace en
bateau tout comme l'avait imposé pierre
ler au riches familles de la
[Musique]
ville à des générations et des
générations c'est ma ville je l'ai dans
le sang je
l'aime et puis mes enfants et ma femme
ils sont
né en grand amoureux de sa ville
l'architecte naval s'est mise en tête de
perpétuer l'œuvre de Pierre Legrand avec
Andrey son bras droit il nous emmène sur
un chantier titanesque le projet de sa
vie ils viennent inspecter les dernières
avancées
[Musique]
à
gauche je veux te montrer quelque
chose il ne devait pas y avoir une
coursive vers le haut non seulement vers
le bas c'estci fait office d'échafaudage
temporaire la se définitive sera
différente il y a 3 ans Vladimir s'est
mise au défi de construire à l'identique
le premier navire de guerre dessiné par
Pierre Legrand lui-même le PO
tava dis-moi qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
depuis la dernière
fois on envoie le bout il ne reste plus
qu'à installer la dernière CCE de la
poue et on aura fini cette
partie à lui seul le squelette du bateau
a nécessité 2000 chaînes
centenaires à terme ce monstre des mers
mesurera 43 m de long et 40 m de
[Musique]
haut a changé la position de la Russie
sur la mer Baltique c'est comme si on
comparait une puissance nucléaire face à
une puissance sans larmes et bien leava
a fait de la Russie une super puissance
en son temp à l'époque Pierre loyait 500
ouvri aujourd'hui Vladimir emplo que 150
mais son habit déf h du
temps comme dans un rêve de petit garçon
fidèle à l'original le PA tava du 21e
siècle aura aussi ses
[Musique]
canons je perce un trou pour
l'emplacement de la mèche du canon pour
qu'on puisse
tirer c'est par là qu'on fera passer la
mèche canon va tirer en
vrai oui pour de vrai mais vous êtes un
spécialiste en
canon non je suis
[Rires]
tourneur mais ça me plaît parce que
c'est quand même l'histoire qu'on
transmet aux générations
futures quiautre que nous pe le
faire allez on prend la dernière tige
remonter de 3 mm Maxime 31 ans est le
responsable de l'atelier des voilure
c'est lui l'ouvrier le plus admiré et le
plus respecté du
chantier dans
les ça c'est le trè
déjà mais viens je te montre sur un plan
où on en
est là ce qui est en ver c'est déjà
fait le grand ma ILT le capitaine
le standard c'était la première frégate
de la flotte russe sur la mer
Baltique il a été construit en 1703 sur
le chantier naval de Ladoga c'est en
Carell et nous nous avons fait la
réplique de ce navire au début des
années 90 à
Saint-Pétersbourg j'ava 10 ans quand
j'ai rejoint l'équipe du standart au
début j' àortter les pièces détachées du
navire ou alors je les comptais
10 an mais comment c'est possible en
Russie tout est
possible contrairement aUard Naig sur
tous les océans du globe le lu
rest son inauguration sapéterbourg
pourra s'enorueillir du plus grand musée
flottant du
mondeve dimensions norme leava serait
bien en peine de naviguer sur la NA
aujourd'hui avenue principale de la
ville le trafic maritime est intense et
les danger
réel dans la zone sud de la ville une
brigade de sauvteur plongeur vient de
recevoir un appel
[Musique]
d'urgence il y a un homme à l'eau je
n'ai pas beaucoup
d'information apparemment il a été
éjecté de son jet
ski il a besoin
d'aide c'est tout ce qu'on
sait été comme hiver les sauteurs de
Saint-Pétersbourg assurent une mission
de service public capital plus de 6000
interventions par
an nous sommes au mois de juin mais la
température de la Neva ne dépasse pas
15°gr le blessé risque l'hypothermie
[Musique]
vas-y cou
il a mal au bras le gauche ou le
[Musique]
droit le
gauche comment tu t'appelles Sacha
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé Sacha j'ai
allé trop vite sur mon jet ski et j'ai
été éjecté et tu as mal où j'ai mal au
bras et à part le bras tu as mal
ailleurs non ça va avec sa douleur au
bras le blessé ne pouvait ni remonter
sur son jet ski ni atteindre seul la
berge il est prê à transporté allez on y
va on va s'occuper de toi tu vas aller à
l'hôpital l'année dernière été et hiver
confondu les anges gardiens de la Neva
ont sauvé la vie de près de 450
personnes malgré tout 120 ont encore
péri dans les eaux froides de la ville
jambes
toi impossible donc pour les softe
plongeur de relâcher leur
vigilance4 ancien plongeur dans l'armée
c'est lui qui dirige les 400 hommes de
la
brigade vous attendez leetour deit
etensite vous pouill le long
du toujours les
mêm j'ai déjà intervenirès de je
ce soir et ses hommes n'ont pas le droit
à l'erreur la ville accueille le plus
grand rassemblement de l'année la fte de
tous les Bach de Russie auourh jour jour
de la Grand fte
plisou
je sont les plus importants de la soirée
aujourd'h
bonjour enlè ta
coule se passe quelque chose leil
démarre vous inform la centrale vous
intervenez canal
5 bien
surors communque
sur 21
juin du pays attend avec impatience le
clou de la
soirée c'est le R de chaque bachelier à
Saint-Pétersbourg d'assister à cette
fête c'est
unique on a notre bun fois dans notre
vie c'est comme cette fête ça n'arrive
qu'une fois dans la vie une seule
[Musique]
fois
à minuit le ciel s'enflamme de 1 feu
pour accueillir les voiles
rouges un bateau mythique qui symbolise
l'avenir de la jeunesse et le renouveau
de
Saint-Pétersbourg
des spectacles comme celui des voiles
écarlates ça n'existe nulle part
ailleurs dans le monde Saint-Pétersbourg
est
unique merci à SaintPétersbourg d' une
ville incroyable et bonne fête à tous
les
[Musique]
B depuis que Poutine le pétersbourgeois
le plus célèbre est devenu maître du
crelin la ville Ren de ses cendres et se
rêve en PH de la nouvelle
Russie
chaque année Saint-Pétersbourg attire
toujours plus de
[Musique]
touristes pour découvrir le cœur de
l'ancienne capitale impériale c'estes
160 km de Canau et ses dizaines de ponts
le meilleur moyen reste encore le
[Musique]
bateau
voilà l'endroit où aujourd'hui je vais
dessiner le
panorama Mar lui n'est pas un touriste
artiste français installé à
Saint-Pétersbourg depuis 11 ans il a le
projet fou de monter une exposition de
tableau en glace en attendant des
températures négatives il profite de
l'été pour terminer une autre vre tout
aussi
insensé une maison j'ai pas encore fin
en 3 ans Marc a peint un à un tous les
édifices de la prospectevski les
champsélysé de saint-péterb
[Musique]
9 km d'architecture concentré sur
seulement 10 m de papier à main
[Musique]
levé unevre unique à laquelle il associe
les
passants
c'est un projet c'est pas long j'ai déjà
dessiné 500 personnes et j'aimerais bien
vous
dessiner c'est grat ça prend juste 5
minutes vous avez du
temps le tableau ça permet de rencontrer
les gens les r sont des fois un petit
peu
timid de m'approcher quand je les
dessine alors de suite contact on peut
parler hisire vien pourquoi ils sont ici
ce qui me plaît c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
de création de créateurs d'artistes de
musiciens et il y a toute cette énergie
que que j'aime beaucoup et à la fois
c'est une grande ville et à la fois il y
a des quartiers des petits c'est comme
un petit village dans la grande ville
donc j'aime beaucoup ça c'est un travail
titanesque vous pouvez m'aider regardez
je vais tout vous montrer
atts ou vous pouvez m'aider tenez-le
pour tout montrer à la petite
fille voilà
voilà si Marc connaî toutes les façades
de la prospectski il connaî aussi les
trésors cachés loin des sentiers
touristiques pour arrondir ses maigres
revenu d'artistes il travaille aussi à
temps partiel comme agent
immobilier bon voyage merci ou attz je
vais prendre votre
valise ses clients cet après-midi une
mère et son fils tout juste arrivés de
France c'est une très vieille
maison bonjour monsieur voil c'est la
vieille sonette d'autre
fois la spécialité de Marc dénicher des
appartements hors du commun qu'il
propose à la location au
touristes alors ici c'est le grand
corridor qui dessert toutes les chambres
avec le vieux linoéum qui date de
l'époque soviétique il y avait cette
famille qui vivait là c'était un
communal cas et il y avait un téléphone
pour tout le monde vous voyez et les
gens pouvaient appeler un définiment
alors il y avait des tas de disputes
autour du téléphone parce qu'il bloquait
le téléphone oui c'était pas payant
c'était gratuit non c'était gratuit à
l'époque ouais alors voilà la chambre
verte d'après moi ici vous serez bien au
calme et en plus avec une pervu sur le
canal oh là
là là vous êtes au au au jour le plus
long au nuit blanche alors comme il y a
pas de volet sont très beau ces rideau
mais vous pouvez les fermer parce que la
nuit vous allez êt réveiller à 4h du
matin on est en pleine nuit blanche il y
a pas de volet du tout non il y a pas de
volet voilà donc n'hésitez pas sinon
vous allez vous allez pas dormir
ouais on essaie de de garder
l'ambiance un peu soviétique et de non
de toutes les époques d'ailleurs on
essaie d'être en Russie le au
maximum il y a 15 ans Dominique
bijoutier de formation est venu
s'installer à Saint-Pétersbourg depuis
elle est devenue plus russe que les
Russes tout comme son appartement on va
continuer si vous voulez
ouais alors ici c'est la salle de bain
tout en bois on dirait presque un sonard
c'est comme is Barus en quel mais oui
c'est très chaleureux pour prendre son
bain c'est très bien
la vue est un peu un peu dure c'est
typiquement
destovski n'oubliez pas qu'on est dans
le quartier on est dans le qu en fait
entre le côté canal et l'intérieur de de
la cour on n pas du tout dans dans la
même ambiance entre les deux les cours
caché ou un peu
sordidesbre en tout cas c'est ça la
Russie lesast
contrast voilà c'est très bien merci
maison alors à votre arrivée à votre
beau séjour ici j'essaie de trouver des
appartements qui ont du charme
qui on va se rappeler de et où où l'art
la Russie Saint-Pétersbourg les couleurs
sont présentes
voilà au plus fort de l'été à ces
latitudes le soleil ne se couche pas
avant
minuit ce sont les fameuses nuits
blanches
ici le sénateor je passe à
[Musique]
Babor ce spectacle touristes et
ptersbourgeois viennent l'observer sur
les quais et sur les bateau
mouches il se pressent aussi pour y
admirer le travail d'un
homme un homme que personne ne connaî
pourtant véritable maître de la
ville
moi je suis comme un policier qui fait
la circulation à
Carrefour je régule la circulation dans
tous les
sens seulement je suis à la manœuvre
d'une technologie ultra puissante de
mécanism super
puissant machine méga
puissante depuis 34 ans Serge est au
manette du pont le plus emprunté de la
ville le pont du palais
1800 tonnes d'acier et 1 million de
boulons il est 1h3 il ne reste plus que
2 minutes et c'est des entrailles du
géant que Sergey impose ses règles au
noctembul la sécurité j'int la
signalisation la circulation arrêtée
plus moyen de passer d'une rive à
l'autre Saint-Pétersbourg se retrouve
coupé en
deux lève les ailes du
[Musique]
pont et voilà c'est
lancé
[Musique]
regardez le spectacle que je vous
offre chaque nuit les 1 de la ville
laiss circuler les gros navir sur la
NA SaintPétersbourg devient alors un
carrefour maritime
majeuritree FL
Russie ne puisse pas éviter
Saint-Pétersbourg lorsque les navires
arrivent d'Europe et qu'ils se rendent
au centre de la
Russie ils doivent obligatoirement
passer par ici par la
NA lac
de et ensuite ils peuvent atteindre le
Nord le Sud ou le centre de la
Russie ad qui est au commande ce soir et
mon filsîné travaille sur le pont
tchkov toute ma famille lève les ponts
moi mes de fils ma
[Musique]
femme à 2h30 du matin le jour pointe
déjà à
l'horizon
les amoureux des nuits blanches eux
profitent d'une dernière valse avant la
fin de
l'été sans avoir vraiment connu
d'automne dès début novembre
Saint-Pétersbourg doit affronter un
hiver
[Musique]
polaire les températures peuvent
descendre jusqu'à 30
en mitouflé les habitants apprennent dès
leur plus jeune âge à résister aux
conditions climatiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
extrêmes
[Musique]
pour Nastia le froid n'est pas un
problème c'est même son
élément cette jeune femme de 24 ans est
championne de nage en eau froide une
pratique typique russe qu'elle va faire
découvrir aujourd'hui à ses
amis wouh l'eau a l'air super
aujourd'hui ouais en plus il fait
vraiment
bon il fait bon c'est ce qu'il nous
faut dans ce bassin creusé au milieu
d'un petit lac sportif confirmé amateurs
s'entraîent tout l'hiver dans une eau à
[Musique]
degr température extérieure ce jour-là 5
de
la spécialité de Nastia c'est le 50 m 50
m et pas un de plus nager davantage
pourrait entraîner arrêt cardiaque et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hypothermie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je viens nager tous les
weekends pendant la semaine j'ai
accumulé beaucoup de stress et donc là
je m'en
débarrasse c'est comme si je renaissais
ça me redonne des forces je me sens en
pleine forme et prête à affronter la
semaine qui
vient
au tour d'Andre de relever le challenge
une première pour
[Musique]
lui oh la
vache
c'est comme si on m'avait retourné la
tête comme si je revenais d'une autre
planète cétait
super je reprends tout juste mes
esprits je su s de l' je saais plus où
j'étaisens pas sera
[Musique]
capable 25 m d'un coupas pas peur ça va
ah ouais super tu vois comme l'hiver
nous fait du bien tous les
[Rires]
deux dans la famille de Nastia tout le
monde est nageur en e froide sa mère
professeur de piano l'a initié dè l'âge
de 2
ans les voilà les photos elles sont
vieilles et toutes
déc et voilà le
moment d'abord c'est moi qui me suis
trempée dans un trou creusé dans la
glace et j'avais l'air si heureuse que
mes enfants ont voulu faire
pareil mon fils avait 11 ans ma F de et
ils ont voulu essayer après ils se sont
sentis si bien ils étai tout joyeux et
surtout si F
de pendant toute son enfance la petite
Nastia se trempe une fois par semaine
dans l'eau glacée à l'adolescence elle
assiste à une compétition de
natation une
révé c'était au bord d'un lac entouré de
montagnes c'était vraiment
beau l'eau était à 4
degr j'ai voulu aller juste m'y tremper
comme je fais d'habitude et puis tout
d'un coup je me suis dit mais pourquoi
est-ce que je ne nagerais pas et je l'ai
fait 2
m tout de suite après j'ai foncé
m'inscrire à la compétition à la
dernière minute depuis ça fait 6 ans que
je participe à des
compétitions de l'or en Estonie de
l'argent en Slovénie elle enchane les
victoires C esprit sportif est très
ancré chez NASA elle veut toujours être
la première
partout dans quelques jours na se rendra
au plus grand rassemblement de beigur en
e froide de la ville
[Musique]
loin des quartiers populaires au pied de
la cathédrale Saint-Nicolas des marins
Marc le dessinateur prépare son
exposition de tableau en
glace pour choisir l'étoile qu'il va
tenter de reproduire il se rend avec son
fils Danille au musée de
l'Ermitage prof de la
glace palais des tar et joyau de
l'architecture baroque russe l'Ermitage
c'est le symbole de Saint-Pétersbourg
mais également avec ses mil salles l'un
des plus grands musées du
[Musique]
mondee tu la
reconnais bonjour bonjour madame bonjour
ça
va même s'il l'a déjà visité à plusieurs
reprise Mar a fait appel à une guide
pour ne pas se perdre dans le musée et
se noyer dans ses quelques 3 millions
d'œuvres
d'art tous les murs VO à droite et à
gauche sont recouverts de petits
portraits ce sont des portraits des
généraux russes les petits format ce
sont des portraits des
généraux regarde un peu toute toute
cette or là madame a dit qu'il avait 20
kg
d'or et voilà nous arrivons à une des
œuvre équipit de Mathis dans la
collection ah ben voilà c'est qui
s'appelle La Ronde la ronde c'est
celle-là là qui est la plus célèbre
c'est le nom que ma avait donné lui-même
à cette uvre la ronde voilà celui-là
danine il nous plaît
hein ça c'est vraiment tout le monde
connaît c'est l'Hermitage c'est mathtis
voilà on va prendre
celui-là je choisis ce tableau déjà par
sa taille parce que nous on a un grand
tableau et puis par les couleurs qui
sont simples et puis par ses par ce
rythme ce mouvement et puis il y a trois
couleurs donc je pense qu' avec de la
glace on va y arriver et comme si
reproduire des tableaux en glace n'étit
pas déjà assez complexe Marc
l'excentrique a décidé de corser encore
un peu plus le
défi tiens puis là tiens regarde tu sais
ce qu'on fait on pourra même trouver un
verre et le coller dans la glince comme
ça on aura pas besoin de s'amuser à
faire le verre bien que le verre la
perspective elle est toute tordue ça va
être très dur de trouver un verre comme
ça je voulais prendre Picasso parce que
Picasso c'est céit mon voisin pendant 11
ans on habitait à 700 m l'un de l'autre
lui à Mougin il est décédé en 1973 je me
rappelle encore de tous les drapeaux
français qui étaient devant sa propriété
on allait même acheter le pain à la même
boulangerie et tous les autres tableaux
de Picasso sont trop dur à faire en
glace et celui-à c'est quand même le un
des plus simples après Matis et Picasso
Marc voudrait aussi rendre hommage au
peintre ruses ah voilà cel est superbe
tableau rege les belles
couleurs ah bah voilà regarde le titre
parfait Zima Daniel l'hiver ah ben
celuià on va le prendre ça c'est j'ai
même pas besoin de regarder les
autres Marc est emballé par un tableau
de
Kandinski je pouvais pas trouver mieux
je savais même pas qu'il existait ce
tableau c'est c'est le tableau qu'il
faut il y a de la glace il y a de la
neige il y a des montagnes il y a le
froid
je le bleu toutes les couleurs voilà il
est là allez on
[Musique]
continue pendant ce temps au pied de
l'Ermitage yy et son équipe font leur
tournée d'inspection quotidienne sur le
golf de
Finlande en hiver sur la mer gelée les
risques de noyade et d'accidents mortels
sont beaucoup plus nombreux qu'en
[Musique]
été tu fais genre c'est ton territoire
ici et
oui première victime les pêcheurs sur
[Musique]
glace allez on est
parti la première consigne c'est de ne
pas aller sur la glace si elle fait
moins de 7 10 cm d'épaisseur en
particulier pour ceux qui viennent en
voiture sur la glace et puis je leur
explique les premiers gestes de
pêchez quoi les
gars le
Gardon voilà un cendre mais je l' pêché
un peu plus loin celui la GL épaisse ici
elle atteint 30 cm non non 15 cm
peut-être 20 15 20 cm c'est pas mal
allez on mesure la
glace il y a souvent des hommes qui
tombent à travers la glace dans le Golf
de Finlande dans la Neva et là
l'expérience et l'excellence de
sauveteur plongeur est déterminante
puisque chaque seconde est vit pour
sauver
[Musique]
un on VI de mesurer la glace sur la
nvale faisait 33 cm même avec le passage
des bris
glace
ça fait même plus ici
35 cette année la glace est
bonne je vous donne ça quand vous aurez
une minute lisezle c'est important quand
même
jeirc c'est bien discuter avec des gars
comme vous parce que parfois on aire des
pêche
bourut parler
autr mais nous on
estbre j'ai 74 ans ça fait déjà bien 20
ans que je pêche sur la glace et je ne
suis jamais tombé à
[Rires]
l'eau voyez comme il est petit
celui-l je lui retire son hameçon pour
qu'il grandisse encore un
peu
aujourd'hui y a un emploi du temps
chargé lui et ses hommes doivent creuser
un bassin dans la glace pour le futur
rassemblement des nageurs en eau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
froide bon vous êtes au courant des
dimensions vous savez à quelle distance
il faut creuser c'est quoi la profondeur
de 4 m
1,50 en plein mois de janvier
FLE est ai que
[Musique]
l'ACI peu à pe les sauvteurs dessinent
une croix dans quelques jours des
milliers de croyants viendront s baigner
pour célébrer le baptême du
Christ une tradition risqué que doit
sécuriser vite pas comme
ça précaution
indispensable demand à hommes
d'exorerond de
il plonge pour vérifier le fond de
l'eau'il N a rien qui pourrait empêcher
l'installation de la structure
en
maisver trouver des déchets car de
MT allô tu vois le fond il y a quelque
[Musique]
chose
bon maintenant on dégage les lieux reste
plus
rien tout est enfin prêt pour la touche
finale comme descendu des cieux une
chapelle est posée au fond du
fleuve de retour à leur base les Ste
plongeurs s'accordent une pause avant
leur prochaine mission après des heures
passé dans le froid ils se sont préparés
du cendre
grillé
de
Finlande faut tout manger même la tête
faut pas jeter c'est trop
bon leste plongeur de garde toute la
nuit à ces latitudes septentrional en
hiver la nuit tombe dès
[Musique]
16h
il est 10h le jour se lève
enfin tu as bien dormi on a fini tar
hier ta femme n'a rien dit dislui que
c'est au nom de l'art depuis de semaines
Marc l'artiste français travaille 18h
par jour pour finir à tend ses tableau
en glace tous les matins il retrouve ses
assistants dans l'arrière-cour de son
immeuble
atieras bienmi
oui alors aujourd'hui je vais faire le
toit et après il faut préparer les
couleurs pour verser pour la
maison tu veux cette couleur
alors oui du jaune et du vert on peut
faire ses fenêtres aussi
ensemble il prépare la future exposition
de marque
hop
hop je crois que j'aurais pu être horors
Fèvre mon voisin pens m'a dit pourquoi
vous travaillez pas à l'intérieur j'ai
dit ben c'est de la glace monsieur alors
il arrivit pas à le croire il a pris ah
oui oui c'est de la
glace Marc doit terminer un tableau de
monnaie très compliqué à copier un à un
chaque trait de pinceau est remplacé par
des morceau de glace
teinté déjà jolé mais dans l'eau chaude
par que la seringue est jolée le bout ça
passe plus l'eau de l'eau ni trop chaude
ni trop froide en guise de colle tout
est question de température je crois
qu'aujourd'huiit 10 9 10 c'est une
température
parfaite 8 c'est trop chaud la chaleur
de MAM va vite faire fondre la glace et
et moin 20 c'est trop froid pour pour
mes
pieds par contre la glace elle est
parfaite est pas
mal enfin moi j'aime bien les conditions
extrêmes Marc a prévu de présenter C
tableaux au public le jour du vernissage
de son
[Musique]
exposition le travail presque terminé ne
reste plus qu'à tracer les lignes noires
sur ver de Kandinski et à
[Musique]
prier si la température réchauffe ben on
sera obligé de leur dire au revoir ils
partiront dans la
[Musique]
rivière
en attendant l'exposition de Marc en
cette journée du 18 janvier au pied de
la forteresse Pierre et Paul on célèbre
l'épiphanie depuis la chute de l'URSS on
assiste en Russie à la renaissance de la
foi orthodoxe et de ses
rite parmi les milliers de fidèles venus
aujourd'hui se baigner dans l'eau bénite
du FLE
[Musique]
Nastia aujourd'hui c'est un jour
particulier on fait tous ensemble
l'épiphanie je suis vraiment contente
heureuse de m'être baigné ici
aujourd'hui pu c'est tellement
beau
le sang russe trouve sa chaleur dans le
froid comme l'a dit un célèbre
[Musique]
écrivain mais le froid n'est pas sans
risque en cas d'hydrocuion la protection
de Dieu ne suffit pas les softeur
plongeurs
[Musique]
veill je vous aide non merci peut-être
quand je
remonterai exceptionnellement y a
délaissé son uniforme réglementaire de
sauveteur attention les gars voilà notre
directeur attention
attention oh
[Applaudissements]
Seigneur je me sens rechargé à fond je
suis plein
d'énergie prêt à travailler beaucoup et
longtemps à retourner le monde avec
l'aide de Dieu
Monsieur après le choc thermique tous
les moyens sont bons pour se
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
réchauffer
cette année 30000 croyants auront
affronté les EAU glacées de la
[Musique]
Neva une semaine plus tard un
réchauffement inhabituel a transformé la
ville en véritable
peoire Mar est inquiet pour ces
tableau
mais là la neige elle
a pas
fondu
ben la température cette nuit est montée
à 1 degr 2°gr maintenant et il pleut en
plus alors il a fallu faire un
sarcophage pour les œuvres d'art pour
pas qu'elle
fonde ça c'est l'œuvre maîtresse et
Matis il faut se dépêcher
que il pleut
maintenant le vernissage de marque est
compromis les heures sont
[Musique]
comptées
oph Marc a prévu de faire son exposition
éphémère au pied des colonnes rostrales
en face de l'Ermitage sur les bords de
la
Neva oh oh c'est lourd on pose
sans autorisation l'artiste doit faire
vite pour ne pas être repéré par la
police on peut le faire glisser pour
plus de discrétion l'exposition sauvage
ne commencera qu'à la nuit
tombée il faut tout
retirer je regarder une
minute il ché un pe mais
pasondevalet éclairage les copies des
tableaux de l'Ermitage vont être dévoilé
en grande pompe sois prêt qui a un
BRI
[Musique]
bravoex la ronde de marque est fidèle à
l'original de
[Musique]
Matis et l'hiver de Kandinski
s'ans suive la meule de foin de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monnaie le clou du spectacle un Picasso
en
reliefass et du V pour
[Musique]
Picasso donc Alissa merci à Alissa et
al merci de m'avoir
supporté ce sont des gens si calmes
contrairement à moi qui suis
volcanique pour couronner son succès
Marc peut compter sur un feu d'artifice
inattendu sans le savoir l'artiste
français a organisé son exposition le
soir de la célébration de la fin du
siège de leningrade en
Saint-Pétersbourg la ville où tout est
possible brille à nouveau de tous ses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
feux